le verger a été créée par mon grand-père
fin des années 40
donc ça a été essentiellement développée
par mon père et mes oncles dans les
années 80 chez les feuillette les vergès
c'est une histoire de famille on récolte
les fruits de fer en fils depuis
plusieurs générations
en ce moment c'est la saison de la
taille le verger se fait autour de 60
hectares on a 25 hectares en production
biologique et ont produit
essentiellement des pommes et des poires
un petit peu de cerises également mais
c'est 25 25 variétés de pommes et sept
variétés de poires les pommes récoltées
dans ses vergers sont destinés au marché
du frais des pommes de table vendus dans
les grandes surfaces et dans les
magasins de la famille feuillette les
fruits déclassés sont transformés en
compote et en jus de pomme depuis
quelque temps l'arboriculteur souhaite
se diversifier
trouver un nouveau débouché pour les
pommes l'idée lui est venue de créer une
boisson apéritive à base de pommes
certes mais différente du cidre son nom
arborigène c'est une boisson fermentée
alcoolisées produite à partir de nos
fruits donc on a créé un process de
fermentation spécifique pour pour cette
boisson là donc on a travaillé pendant
un peu plus de quatre ans à la enfin
heureux à la recherche et développement
sur ce produit là et on a abouti à un
process bien spécifique donc c'est
vraiment une boisson unique qui n'existe
pas qui n'existe pas ailleurs
à la base ce taux monte de femmes sont
ajoutés des infusions de plantes et de
fruits
la boisson se décline en trois saveurs
et trois couleurs on trouve la boisson
dans certains bars restaurants qu'à
lister quelques magasins encore peu
connu sa présence au salon de
l'agriculture devrait la faire passer à
la vitesse supérieure ça va nous
apporter une visibilité à plus grande
échelle mettre en avant notre produit
montrer la spécificité de dar morigène
de rencontrer tout de suite et
immédiatement une grande palette de
clientèle qu'on n'aurait pas l'occasion
nous de rencontrer en 2020 la famille
feuillet de prévoit de produire entre
250 et 300 mille bouteilles